you know for the longest time
my uh my inner life
has been in turmoil there's been a
battle between my desire for novelty and
adventure for endless
adventure and novelty and also my
desire for communion my desire for
love my desire for marriage my
desire to soul mate because
there's nothing obviously that i want
more than
to mate souls with someone right to
to create a life world together to raise
children together to make life with
together the kind of union soulful
spiritual and embodied union
um that might heal us of our
fractures and might allow us to grow and
develop in ways we cannot even
fathom i'm looking for that partner that
life
partner and and i long for that with a
with a kind of aching
uh ferocity right it's it's something
that is missing from my life yet
simultaneously my
desire to soar through the sky like a
bird to be
free as a bird to adventure
endlessly to explore forever right
there's this
desire for otherness for a whisper of a
thrill
right and i'm chasing novelty i'm i'm
chasing the edge of the
horizon and and finding a way for those
worlds to
intermediate to find each other has been
quite difficult my love
of novelty has felt like a threat to
many of my
lovers it has made them fear that i
wouldn't be there for them always
because eventually i'd grow bored
and i'd want to soar and escape
the trivialities of the everyday there
was a terror
of the holiness of the sacred union
fading right there's this idea that
routine deadens everything and so
you find the one you fall in love you
get married and then you feel like
you're in a prison there's always been
this anxiety
about the imprisoning effects of habit
and that you might grow
tired of a person there's something
called hedonic adaptation and so that's
the problem because you want
union but then hedonic adaptation says
that eventually you'll just grow
tired and trapped and restless with this
person or at least that's the fear
and that's what happens to so many
people they no longer are able to see
each other meanwhile the search for
novelty in the search for adventure
is always about blasting our eyes and
blasting our hearts open right the
thrill of something new
to travel beyond the horizon always
jolts us
into awakenedness you know awakening
and so this desire to have both
elements right to have to have the
thrill
to have the
the incandescent and effervescent thrill
of adventure and novelty and yet
and yet
ah and yet to not lose sight
of of the glories to be found in
in intimate commitment and communion in
building a home and planting a garden
with someone you know in
in in in making someone part of your
everyday
part of your life world this is equally
uh
equally important and
you know they say you can't have it all
but i think what constantly
uh jolts and agitates uh me is this
desire not to compromise for one or the
other but actually to
find both right to find a partner you
know that i can actually soar
together with you know that we can
endlessly explore
together um with and um
well
i'll keep you posted